aujourd'hui une vidéo spéciale pour
venir vous parler un petit peu de
l'évolution de la chaîne il ya beaucoup
de choses cette année beaucoup de choses
qui se lance j'en ai déjà parlé lorsque
j'ai effectivement annoncé le début de
la saison 3 il ya notamment justement la
fonction était donc je viens vous parler
aujourd'hui c'est la possibilité de
rejoindre la chaîne de devenir membre
soit parti d'un tim grubb avec le bouton
rejoindre qui affichait sous la vidéo
maintenant sur le côté je sais pas si
c'est vrai je crois que cela doit être
ici un monde à vie normalement ça doit
être là et lorsque vous arrivez aussi
sur la chaîne façon un peu plus globale
vous avez le bouton en haut rang je vais
vous expliquer dans quelques instants à
quoi sert ce bouton rejoindre comment ça
marche c'est tout ça tout ça
[Musique]
nous
l'idée c'est quoi c'est qu'en fait il ya
souvent beaucoup de personnes qui font
des dons et c'est hyper gentil par
paypal j'avais mis à lire dans la
description pour pouvoir le faire si
vous souhaitiez le faire et il ya des
personnes qui le font et du coup il ya
quelques temps quelques mois l'idée a
émergé de me dire mais pourquoi est ce
que je pourrais pas rejoindre je dois
utiliser ce bouton rejoindre vu que j'ai
passé les 100 mille abonnés année
dernière donc le bouton est devenu
accessible
donc je travaillais dessus et ci de voir
ce que je pouvais vous proposer comme
contrepartie
et de quelle manière je pouvais le faire
pour que ce soit intéressant pour tous
alors du coup en travaillant dessus il
ya trois paliers qui sont arrivés alors
l'idée c'est que si vous cliquez sur le
bouton rejoindre il vous allez pouvoir
rejoindre la communauté à partir de là
tim grubb me permettre de faire évoluer
la chaîne ça me permettra effectivement
financer différents projets notamment
vous savez quand je pars à las vegas par
contre une fortune tous les voyages que
je fais la plupart du temps ces sont des
marques qui m'a vite mais il y en a que
je paye notamment le csa vegas pour
l'instant c'est tout ma poche donc la
saga le studio ici tout à équiper
certains d'entre eux aussi des gros
budget et puis je regarde un peu plus
loin à l'avenir
l'idée c'est l'année prochaine j'en
regarde de pouvoir embaucher quelqu'un
embauche un menteur un menteur une
menteuse pour pouvoir effectivement
nommé des dans cette tâche là qui
compliquait non j'adore cette tâche tout
causé la plus intéressante parce que
c'est aussi la plus créative mais une
des plus chronophage en tout cas parce
que ça demande beaucoup de temps de
temps de travail pour pouvoir
sentant une vidéo tous les jours monte
donc ça me permettrait effectivement
d'être en tout cas une des clés pour
pouvoir financer un poste donc quand sa
boîte
franchement hyper hyper cool ça me
permettrait également de pouvoir acheter
du matériel pour faire évoluer la chaîne
caméras et micros compagnie je vous en
passe et des meilleurs ballons beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de choses à faire
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de choses à
raconter
et justement bien le fait que vous
puissiez être vous membres de la chaîne
permet de nous soutenir et de m'aider à
faire il voit tout ça sert tout cas une
des clef de l'équation ses coûts et donc
j'ai décidé justement dans des
différents pays alors il ya trois
paliers différents le premier palier
c'est un euros 99 par mois sans
engagement vous pouvez arrêter à tout
moment comme vous voulez alors vous avez
différents avantages premier avantage
vous avez pas si ça se vend bien écrit
en c 2 couleurs j'ai pas de marqueur
indélébile et c'est le nouveau studio il
faut que j'achète vous investissiez
secrète marqueur indélébile
il y en a sur son badge personnalisé
l'idée c'est qu'effectivement et bien
lorsque vous arrivez vous allez avoir un
badge qui à côté de votre votre nom sur
tous les commentaires que vous aller
poster puxi sur le sur le chat est sûre
les live qu'on fera très bientôt donc on
en reparlera ultérieurement de ça aussi
donc vous allez donc avoir un badge
personnalisé êtes nouveau vous arrivez
donc votre badge greu badr eu un mois
creux de moi je vois six mois jusqu'au
12 mois bayrou 24 mois c'est hyper cool
ensuite vous avez ici les émoticônes
leur terre vous avez des des émoticônes
complètement personnalisé et que
uniquement les membres peuvent avoir
soit c'est assez rigolo fonctionnalités
assez marrante donc pour l'instant gagné
1,6 plus j'aurai membres plus je
pourrais en proposer d'autres posteurs
foot à caussens à 6
je pars en faire un autre et puis si
d'ailleurs vous avez des suggestions des
idées de d'émoticônes rigolote je suis
preneur pris ensuite vous avez ça ma
reconnaissance éternelle et tout mon
amour jusqu'à ce que mort s'ensuive donc
racheté ça c'est plutôt cool c'est le
premier palier ensuite vous avez le
deuxième palier à 4 euros 99 alors que
vous avez tous les avantages du premier
palier badge emoticon et bien évidemment
maroc reconnaissance éternelle c'est
tout
c'est pour vous c'est cadeau et vous
avez ensuite un truc vachement cool
c'est une contrainte pouvoir le proposer
ça vous prenez le contrôle de la chaîne
alors l'idée fait que en fait alors
c'est pas vous qui allez tous décidés ou
plus vous et vous le dites il faut de
tester le nouveau sifflé tata yoyo nous
n'avons certes un peu un peu dangereux
mais par contre l'idée c'est que je vais
vous proposer différents sujets par
exemple sous forme d'art sultats ça ça
ça et ça comme produit lequel vous
voulez conteste aujourd'hui c'est vous
qui choisissez
et comme ça je verrai ce qui les attend
que vous les plus pressantes et on
parlera de ses étudiants priorité vous
allez prendre le contrôle de la chaîne
et précises et des questions mais
évidemment tout ça tout ça tout ça tout
ça je vous soumettrai ça ouvre tout ça
c'est vous qui allez me dire ça c'est
pas à ce manque ou extraits moment pour
le faire avec vous ensuite vous avez ici
statut plus axé privilège au forum
je vous l'avais déjà dit dans quelques
jours va arriver le forum sur mon site
l'idée de ce forum c'est un peu de le
dire est de réunir la communauté et les
demandes et chez beaucoup de personnes
qui me contactent facebook twitter
instagram en commentaire bien évidemment
il ya beaucoup de questions notamment
quant à l'achat de smartphones lequel
choisir lequel est le meilleur
et qu'est ce que tu portes de celui là
et c'est des questions auxquelles
malheureusement j'ai pas le temps de
répondre
je ne veux pas c'est vraiment pas une
mauvaise volonté mais si je le fais ça
va me prendre facilement tous les jours
une demi journée à une journée autant
dire que la journée de travail à des
mortes et c'est pas possible et en
publiant une vidéo par jour
c'est pas possible du coup je me suis
dit je vais offrir la possibilité à
toutes ces personnes de venir dans un
seul et même endroit pouvoir justement
poser des questions il ya donc les
personnes qui sont en demande
il y aura d'autres personnes qui ont une
expertise et qui vont pouvoir être là et
tout le monde à pouvoir se regrouper et
puis échanger est-il et des bonnes
astuces des trios et il ya des personnes
qui ont des expertises et qui prend
vraiment conseillé
moi je serai là aussi pour modérer tout
ça pour regarder tout ça et pour
prétendre question une fois de plus dans
la mesure du temps possible on en
reparlera mais donc y aura une partie
spéciale une section spéciale pour la
team pour les personnes qui sont membres
de la communauté
vous aurez votre forum en interne vous
et pouvoir communiquer de façon un peu
plus privilégiés avec un peu moins de
monde de sueur c'est tout nouveau et ça
se mettre en place mais ce soir ce sera
donc ça va se passer et vous aurez bien
évidemment un statut privilégié le
statut de la team bredon classé what the
fuck c'est vachement cool enfin un
dernier qui est à 9 99
vous aurez accès aux coulisses au quiz
de la chaîne l'idée effectivement c'est
de me dire moi je vais vous voyage
beaucoup et des déplacements il ya
beaucoup de choses beaucoup de trucs un
peu cool hyper cool des fois il ya des
choses que je ne peux pas toujours
partagé parce que voilà dans une vidéo
c'est un peu compliqué et des fois qu'il
faudrait faire dévier beaucoup plus
longue et c'est pas possible je me suis
dit hé bien pourquoi pas faire une vidéo
dans lesquels vous aurez plein de
coulisses plein de aof alors j'aimerais
voir comment structurer sa une par mois
est ce que c'est vraiment vraiment hyper
funky et ils perdront donc il n'oubliait
pas un 9,99 vous avez les avantages de
1,99 aux avantages de 4,99 et vous avez
en plus les coulisses que les autres
n'auront pas nos gars ça c'est hyper
cool voilà un peu pour l'idée le tableau
le portrait alors soyez rassurés si vous
n'avez pas la possibilité financière si
vous ne souhaitez pas ou si le côté
membres c'est pas votre prime la dass
est absolument aucun problème ça change
absolument rien entre nous c'est
toujours les bienvenues dans les vidéos
et bien heureusement dans les
commentaires en dessous des vidéos bien
évidemment le forum vous aurez un accès
de la même manière mais pas à l'axé man
mais un accès toujours absolument aucun
souci là-dessus soyez vraiment rassuré
là dessus mais par contre n'est voir par
là ça change absolument rien d'accord il
n'y a absolument aucun problème et on
continue à faire une vidéo car jo et il
doit faire la même chose
rien ne change de ce côté là si par
contre vous souhaitez le faire et que ça
vous intéresse quelles que soient les
allier après je sais que pour beaucoup
de personnes même déjà 2 euros par mois
ça représente de l'argent c'est un
budget donc vous choisissez si vous
souhaitez le faire faites ce que vous
pouvez faire vous mettez pas en
difficulté
s'il ya un mois vous pouvez mois vous
pouvez pas n'y a pas de souci c'est vous
qui choisissez vous sentez pas
prisonnier en tout cas si vous voulez si
vous pouvez vous êtes toujours les
bienvenues centre est extrêmement
plaisir comment le faire c'est
extrêmement simple vous cliquez sur le
bouton rejoint que vous avez ici en
dessous dans la vidéo pour aussi cliquer
sur le bouton rejoindre directement
depuis la chaîne vous choisir votre
moyen de paiement carte bleue paypal
compagnie tout ça et ensuite on est
parti donc voilà ma chance ça plutôt
cool je vous invite bien évidemment à
venir nous rejoindre pour permettre de
mettre en place tous ces projets très
heureux de pouvoir lancer ça aujourd'hui
et j'ai hâte que vous fassiez partie
intégrante de la tim grubb voilà c'est
cool
tassé de l'installation quand même
monsieur cougnaud iphone tu m'as fait un
super set up pour tourner les sûretés
les nouveaux iphone c'est ça va dit
comme ça comment tu parles pour qui fait
des vidéos
alors là je pars normalement pas dit
quand je tourne je fais salut tout le
monde j'espère que vous allez bien
aujourd'hui dans cette nouvelle vidéo
n'a pas la main voir comme ça moi quant
à ta pas la même voix et c'est possible
avec de parler comme ça je parle j'ai en
fait je parle beaucoup plus fort quand
je sens mes vidéos mais oui il s'agit
d'un problème quand j'ai un peu le
timbre de tavaux essayé de parler comme
ça salut c'est quand un salut c'est
quentin en poste à vos affronte pago
selon lui tous ses copains et au fond de
la voix salut à tous ses cantons
salut à tous ses cantons sans suite tous
sensuelle massacre
[Musique]